a powerful storm system pounded the deep
south was strong wind and rain and
caused heavy weekend damage that's
blamed for at least four deaths in the
area record-setting rain left entire
neighborhoods under water along the Ohio
River in Indiana yesterday and the
National Weather Service says 12
tornadoes were reported across Tennessee
Kentucky Arkansas and Missouri on
Saturday those powerful storms ripped
off roofs and flattened homes David beg
no is in Clarksville Tennessee about 40
miles northwest of Nashville in one of
the hardest hit areas David good morning
good morning this is what happened it's
not o'clock at night when the tornado
rolls through it takes off the second
story of this home with a clean cut
almost like somebody had a knife and
sliced it off then it tosses it about 5
yards no one was hurt when the tornado
hit this home debris litters the tree
line here and the tornado then hopscotch
through the area winds were told were up
to 125 miles per hour when it moved
through under the cover of darkness
across the central and southern us
suspected tornadoes mangled cars flipped
RVs and shredded roofs we just turned
around and the roof is just gone in
Mississippi County Arkansas a possible
tornado tore through the roof of that
Motel destroying nearly two dozen rooms
we got in the closet and it was like
turnips like Adam out of it newlyweds
Heather Edwards and her husband Adam
watched as a barn flew over their house
in Robertson County Tennessee as a
suspected tornado plowed through their
property we're just lucky to be alive
everything can be replaced the sheriff
here in Clarksville Tennessee says eight
homes were destroyed and dozens more
damaged as two tornadoes hit this area
that house was flattened but among the
wreckage hope rescuers work quickly to
remove debris because they saw a dog
trapped underneath it looks like they've
got the dog out
just across the Tennessee border in
Logan County Kentucky 79 year old Dallas
Jane combs died when her home collapsed
on top of her during a tornado her
husband John was outside laying down
sandbags Tammy Brown is their daughter
it took the roof off it sucked him back
through the basement the combs would
have celebrated 60 years of marriage in
just a few months all he can tell me is
the love of my life is gone and I can't
live by myself because I've never been
by myself so before Saturday night's
tornado related death we had the longest
stretch without a tornado related death
from May of last year until Saturday
night when this all happened
Gail I was just talking to the public
information officer here in Montgomery
County Tennessee and she told me there
was one home where a family took shelter
in a bathtub the home was destroyed
collapsed around them but they were
unharmed in that bathtub which is always
a good place to go good note to remember
thank you very much David